are you born ready
hey YouTube time like subscribe
I'm doing horrible now this is going
horribly I was trying to help your house
out what brick anyone want brick
anyone want Rock
what about sheep one rifle one sheep
don't look now I got you guys cornered
I got my guns pointed at you
over there
four
four miles four
of these nuts that was a false role but
whatever a false roll what is that I
mean it was all interesting
you're the only one that's four if I
can't roll I hit if I sentence you for
the crime of virginity another form
well
enjoy all your ores wait that's why you
wanted to be four yeah
who has a tree
here we go
does anyone have a train maybe next time
roll a tree Ridge no
um
no all right I guess I'll have to do
this why did you say his first and last
name
I don't know
it's up to you
so there if you need it not there if you
don't oh this is so close
the range
oh no you knew that was gonna happen why
did you just dangle that road out there
and then build a road right now I know
that's what I was telling him this is
Pennsylvania
we have good infrastructure
good job good job
there's that is that count roll again
come on sits right there
if Dylan's bounce back house
doesn't help me much but
yeah does anybody want wood yeah yes
brick or brick no I'll give you a break
come on
think about who's got your back is
America
you're winning she's winning that's true
but Hans always wins in the end he's
gonna end up winning
I still have a chance
[Music]
wait for uh sheep
sheep
dog I'll take a sheep wait oh boy wait I
mean no no no I want a sheep uh I want a
shade I'll take a wait for that's right
it is yeah I don't want that let me just
slide us
up
I'm gonna get a good roll watch this
nine come on
oh my Lord
I called my shot
I only have one okay
I was trying to cut you off
Maybe
oh
sorry did I hook something up
does anyone have a brick I know you have
a brick little hand what do you have I
got anything you need what do you need I
need a rock and a wheat
I'll give you a week
that's all I got no I need a I need a
oh you're talking or in the business
no I need two wow what about two brick
for one of those what about one or one
hey
I'm good oh you're good we'll see about
that
let's see about that
it's a rough game for old Hans
whoa
do you have uh one last one let's go
um
okay
I'm gonna do this and this and build a
city
why'd you put that in two ore in a hi so
that you're plenty
you have to do that because I have two
broth one way I got two resources so one
rock one week two
nice okay
um
it's actually good
foreign
from one friend to another
thank you I'll keep that in mind when
I'm placing new cities until friendships
are usually reciprocated that's all I'll
say
that's not what have you done for me
it's what have you done for me very
Slack
I do yeah yeah you need a week
no no I need a wood
I need a wood
real bad
I have a Woods just wait if anyone needs
a wheat or a sheep
let's make that happen
six
I don't think I need Wood anymore
[Music]
bridge I could make you a very Sheep Man
but if he likes being a human
still see the Sheep time she wrench
um are they screaming
so that's two settlements in a road
you can't even do oh yeah
you can you can't do two settlements and
a road yeah
one here
oh a nice tree for a while
I don't know should I go through we
already have so many 11. oh stacking up
on the 11s oh wait 11's never getting
rolled
me and when they do you're gonna have
four of them
it's higher than messed up
three
last time
oh
yeah it's about it's about much eh
does anyone want a sheep
yeah
you do have a hay
what the hell who's in the lead because
I just I want to get a resource why not
um because it's not on you bridge has
five
Bridges won the road away from here
do you have a wheat I do do you have
wheat no I don't believe that I don't
have it I don't have any resources how
can I over the most people at once
though it's kind of hard now you're
thinking like a true capitalist very
tricky
yeah I don't give a it doesn't it's
gonna
oh no I can't do that it's just
something I thought I can do this okay
yeah
eight flow through you
I hope you now became a chance at it
[Laughter]
heads or tails are from where I'm
sitting well who does the robber
he's got an old Monkey Wrench in his
hand
s
God loves me yes he does he loves
everyone especially the Jews this is
true and the chosen people
oh this is life isn't it
an awesome God he reigns from heaven
above with wisdom power and love my God
is
nine
yeah yeah
funny that everyone knows that song
I didn't know you guys are Christians
[Music]
it sounds insincere for some reason not
until now
actually I really yeah
it's meaningful I love that song
[Music]
is the YouTube enjoying the gospel is
that big
chord
they're loving Ridge they're saying
who's the homeless guy
how do I seem homeless
they say such a thing they just grasp
against straws
thank you
why because they see he that's what Han
said
they said they're grasping at straws
they're just trying to describe you
[Music]
know
five five
oh I got another one
would anyone like some sheep
genuine like some wood
put the Undertaker on it I don't want to
know if um losing you know and foreign
Ridge is winning by the way yeah
wait I haven't oh
that's my point is to be
one two three four
um no no I thought we had a a deal since
wow and
since the beginning of the game almost
five four what's that six oh
at least that's it
what was it actually I don't want to
know
what do you mean what was it I don't
know what I gave you
uh
well at least you didn't block that 11
you guys
five damn it I should have blocked your
vibe
[Music]
because I didn't have a brick brick
squad yes what do you need weight and
sheep I have sheep how many brick do you
have did you just roll I like five
okay I'll give you two sheep for two
brick
yeah
one man
on this road three
oh no one two three four oh I guess one
never mind one away we'll see about that
six
it worked are you sure that was six yeah
and I'll change that okay
who wants brick should I put this
without my straw I need weight
for wheat I'll tell you what
what you said you need weight yeah
um
I'll give you
two sheep for breakfast
so generous
such a giver these days huh no no plan
no Sinister plants
just like
oh let's go Hans
[Music]
has five points
oh you have pretty much nine well
seven until you build the road and then
you'll have then she has she has an arm
she's one way from the Army she's one
way from the Army and she's one way from
the longest road she's one way from
foreplay You're Gonna Take Me Over Hans
block both of us do you want the game to
last longer or not
really I have to okay you're like two
away from winning basically
pons is closer
Hans is like he's got one road to beat
his two is that true and one night and
you need one night to get along this
Army okay
I mean I don't have any
how many Democrats do you have hunt no
no I played mine
oh Hans has seven points
Ponce is gonna be chasing one of the
straw though
oh thanks that was respectfulness
four
good for you guys
I think that's awesome
I shouldn't
move it actually but I'm going to
and then you could put it here wait what
don't you have resources too
you don't uh you only have one app oh
you only have one access to wito I hope
you have it over there too
all right oh no that's your only access
to rock can I take that back and not
play it no
you you have to move it somewhere right
yeah why aren't you doing this that's
crazy
I'm not doing my only brick
but why would you want me to go there
because it's more about Hans than me I
don't care I don't want him to win
oh
Talent oh okay I'm not a threat
you're gonna take from me
you're acting surprised
don't do that you were toxic crazy
wait wait
four good for you guys
have fun
oh you blocked my hair psych
[Laughter]
uh anyone have a wood no he does he took
mine
what do you want what a brick or a sheep
you're trading with the Devil
he's trying to block out you're trying
to block Ally yeah oh so he can get
another point and then win he already
has seven I have nothing why
I need to block her right I'm not even
being what do you need brick that's
crazy
all the way over here it's fine I can go
over here I'm gonna go right here
um
but then I'll still go do you have
anything what else do you have sheep
he's gonna win on this I'll take a sheep
crazy you think he's gonna win this
round two more rolls rolls he's gonna
win
mark my words let's let's
look well I am sexist
[Laughter]
enjoy your zero settlements over there
seven pointless Road stupid ass foreign
[Laughter]
stuck at seven
that's me
oh that was so funny if you took from
Ally I should have made let her build
that road so they attacked her more hmm
it's okay I'll be fine
these short ass roads
I got a sheep and a tree
no thank you Dylan might get longest red
I don't know he has no wood but he has
to support
whatever either way I'm not winning
anymore
they're wondering why you're hanging out
with us losers
me yeah
um Katan is more important than the
people I play with
six
oh you guys should have blocked my six
that's such a bummer no
you mean one brick I'm so afraid yeah
definitely they call them Rich homeless
I was on lights out when they was made
for wine
my boyfriend said that if you do a
special you should call it hand sold
[Laughter]
and Gretel
um I'll trade a settlement for a city
and more for that I'll trade all of this
just keep in mind he's got a lot on the
board first this is the game everyone's
out for themselves it's it's a it's a
settlement and two extra cards
wait no it isn't I'm missing the brick
but anyways this for a city
battery is not included wait that
doesn't make any sense
that doesn't make any sense
um it's a weird deal this so this for
two Rock and we no no no two Rock just
two rock yeah yeah two rocks anyone
who likes this
is some music would be nice
royalty-free music
I'm trying to decide what I'm doing
um but give me one second you gotta get
art list
go ahead
okay
they're not working somebody has it now
no well I do
two people Dave oh I do wait what'd you
guys 12 12 12. yeah what is your vote
rich
six
spray
royalty free on YouTube some of them are
labeled royalty free and then they're
not so then you play it and then they're
like take it down
that's a good idea that's a good scam
what would that accomplish well get
doesn't the person that the non-royalty
fee get paid
oh wait nevermind oh wow oh
no suddenly
where's my other red
that's not that's this
was it that way no no it was the other
way it doesn't matter but oh yeah yeah
it does because you could have put a
settlement there
what's that one just hanging out no I
kind of put a settle in there
five
do you have
looking for Rock
looking for a rock in our place
looking for a rock in all the wrong
places oh no I'm Hans is
running the idea
uh
uh that's not that good
Hills
how do we over
well let's see he already has longest
roads who doesn't need more roads he
needs more settlement so we need goat or
hay
I had any cards
here a lot of people
I'm not winning so this is uh
why don't you have more hope in yourself
and
[Music]
I can play to people over which is
what I'm about to do well Hunt is going
to win right well
what what what resource does he have
access to does he not have access to he
doesn't have access to this is his only
rock yeah but he doesn't need Rock to
build he was already on there too oh it
was already on eight this is the best
bet
and then just no one gets Hans sheep he
only has one access to
Rick
okay yeah but he doesn't need any more
bricks yeah
um
he still has access to sheep here yeah
but how often is free getting old
two twice
no
Bridge
thank you guys for being on my show what
a great show it sounds really fun
about to be helpful it was the journey
not the destination
31 8.
come on that way
what stone did I do I let my comedy show
at the Vulcan yeah thanks for having us
oh yeah
you guys come to it
I was rap hey they were a great
audience and it was packed out it's
packed I thought they were a little
quiet
but it's not like they didn't like it
again I think yeah tense
no do you want or
yeah but I don't have anything to give
you or she
um
two six seven
you need two more
seven
Allison
cops
she's winning right
yeah
I'm not winning
I'm tied with Mr Sullivan
you wanna come around
yeah I take it because it's a battle I
take
yeah let me Court favor with you eight
it's just gone oh it's ten
acceptance
[Music]
actually I didn't think of this
but I got one of these bad boys and I'll
do uh
um I think that's the best night
he only has one brick he can move the
robber
oh my God you guys are puppets of a big
alley
I'm just trying to keep a good game it's
not about winning for me I would like to
do you think that's the worst spot for
you
I don't know you're gonna put it yeah
what are you offering four or what how
many can you give me
do you have any hay I do have it could
have a or and a head first oh wait
actually I don't because I'm gonna get a
duck card I'll give you two sheep for or
in the hay
uh
oh you're not on any sheep huh oh yeah
you're on one you're on a two one two
looks like you're not gonna be getting
much shape these days I'll tell you what
though
you give me a sheep
and you've got yourself a rose
I really need a ride
do not
it's how many roads I'd rather take a
hour and a half yeah exactly well we're
all tied
we're all tied except for Hans yeah
look
we're all done at five and you're at
seven whoa how do you what is that are
you updating that it's a scoreboard it's
like it's like the NFL human AI who
if only it is automatic it's just read
the board
yeah they can check if you're cheating
oh and you should get that you should
try to get a digital one or you just hit
a button yeah yeah like a huge iPad yeah
that'd be so much easier I think you
could do it I think you can find it out
there you could just have 12 connections
all right guys we got a trade for y'all
y'all aren't gonna want to miss it wood
for a rock
Rock
go back to your whole Golem wow
switching things up
oh
six points I can't control my
circumstances I can only control of how
I react to them
foreign
so it just goes directly into the table
there we go
cat loves to rub itself on my shirt
anyone want an ore no
Dylan you're so friendly a minute ago
I've been friendly
I'll give you an orc what are you
looking for a brick please so I can get
longest road
the good point I don't think
like she doesn't have a development card
yet though right no she does um
now we're fighting between no one okay
the lesser of two evils
this is like
oh
anyways
three was rolled I'm glad I caught
myself on that I only got some wheat
Okay who wants Rock I need wood and
brick if you don't want Ally to get
longest road
I already have it
well I don't want you to keep it so
well she has a development card yeah and
I have six points
six points I'm telling you that right
now oh you have a victory card yeah so
I'm just saying even with that
no I don't believe it it's actually a
night card
she's trying to trick Us by saying it's
one less than it is
well I'll show you
don't fall for it oh God two four six
witchcraft it's not
I'm just gonna win you cop two
four six seven eight he's an eight nine
[Music]
wait that's six my bad sorry guys nine
is sheeps
they don't have any sheep wheat sheep
weight
is that GPS is that sheep I have
sheep
I do too
much
yeah wait
what do you want
um
cheap
I actually like that right
you probably do because you don't have
any wait who has longest roads still
hunt right one two three four five six
seven for an hour
you're at five um
you want sheep
[Music]
I already showed him like that part I
can't get them oh that's dangerous
though because then you're
you have the Five Points lined up
you just have to roll the dice
oh it would put me with it
still not even
the ones doesn't have anything that
great let's do what you want to do look
at me I'm on the edges the only thing is
is Hans has to get two more cities all
right
uh I'll do a brick for a week oh wait I
don't want to wait no I have a
brick I need a week
doing what you want
I don't give you a wood do you want
another sheep no
Shop's closed
it's shops close
good daddy
so any cool stories from the road oh boy
did you ask someone asked about Salt
Lake in Vegas
oh I did a show in Park City Utah for
the owner of Zappos oh I heard about you
guys before he died I heard about that
seven oh yeah he like flies comedians
out because he's ready to take us on a
tour and he took us on a tour bus like
Justin Bieber Style
and then we went to his place it was
crazy it's Justin Bieber known for his
two of us I don't know just any kind of
pop star we were on like a big tour bus
we had our own little beds didn't he
like burned his house down or something
what did you do seven
oh that might have helped us
oh no hold on
the funny place to put it I'm just
where do I have six I know I haven't I
always remember here nice
nice
another Debbie
says she has six right now not a good
one I'll tell you that
it's not gonna help me much
one two three are you done it's your
turn yeah I don't know it could be a
night it could be a night why would you
tell us that's that's bad gameplay I
know but I'm not great at lunch four or
five six oh Another One Bites the Dust
foreign
I'm back to square one now
to a degree yes yeah that's something
that I would probably play easily wow
all right
but he's stealing for me
who has a weight
is the music crying just over the
computer yeah can they hear it in here
yeah they can hear it Richard
I got sheep
oh I got a brick sure
I don't know why I'm doing that but you
were nice to me that one around
and investing like three roads
you should have 15 right
still have it
I just can't extended very far well you
have a lot of depth what what is this
man doing over here
oh you gotta keep biggest army no you
gotta get biggest army
draw four cards trans cards wild cards
yeah let's help Ali get a death card
no
no let's help Sullivan
I'm not getting any good ones
give me a five
guys
this is the second time that happened
classic
that's five
yeah
whoa two four six you have seven points
give five
Bridge F7
ten
I need more goat can you pass some goat
sheep sorry
sorry
that's just animal
recognition
what if you had terrible animal
aminal replication you see a cow and
you're like ah it's a goat
everything's a goat
a goat is the goat of being the goat
um
wow what are you doing all right put
your stone put your R where I can see it
no put your arm no where I can see it
damn
this feels like a hostage situation
American history that's it
have you ever have you ever done the who
has ore and then everyone says I have
some
and then you lay him down have you
played it live very much
what in person
um does anyone need wood
it's not condescending it doesn't need
wood I'm sorry I'm nagging
oh no no come around here very often do
you
have 10.
ugh
nice
five let's go damn it you will
check my five
all right I'm gonna take that largest
army oh wow
let's go
can you break down what the yeah what's
the score is that seven seven five eight
who's eight me
it is
I'm in the last one two three four five
six seven eight nine that one has nine
points what oh wait no that's rich
no no Rich has seven
makovski is really faltering
because of all these
you were so cool so close to Whitney
all right we can all settle this if
someone gets done Ally has a one point
in her hand too
cards yeah
[Laughter]
and I got more
I don't know how like how can I help you
I need a break
if I put down another road do I beat
homes no
one two three four five six seven one
two three four five six seven eight
and you need two more
I just gave for you
six
two three four five points plus the one
in your hand oh yeah that's true
technically secret of sex
still not much
whatever do what you want make your own
mistakes
does anyone else have sheep
and you need a brick I would like a
brick okay
I'm running out often times I don't know
what to do villain is like the bank over
here you trade with him
oh look at that helping Dylan out
oh
the big road
to nowhere
this has been such a long game I know
all right wheels are bread
am I like I can't I gave you my brushes
[Laughter]
um I have brick and I need cash now
he's about to win
that'd be a great comeback seven
seven
sound um
you know what to do Ridge when you roll
a seven
wait
Hans is the one winning right now I
don't have any cards
yeah exactly well we don't want Hans to
make cities cities bad for haunts so
where can Hans kids
he needs more room
why would you tell him that aim for her
brick
I'm gonna do some shopping
give me some shopping
don't go for the place where you think
that she'll think I'm not even looking
at it so this will be random for all of
us
yes you don't know what you take
better not being a
you want that bag yeah
wait
whoa wait how many points do you have
not many seven
what's he gonna do with weight build a
city and I'll have nine
you can give the one I'm not gonna build
a city I'm not gonna build a city not
this round no I'm good come on no Enjoy
the woods anywhere else anyone else no
and you
three yeah
I've been forgetting to get that five I
think bummer bummer almost like being
inattentive is bad for you
so I don't know what I'm using this is
wow that's good to know
so that's cool that you went to the
Zappos someone in this house before he
died in a house fire yeah you died in
that house fire yeah how could he knock
it out
too much money in the way
it's the old green thing you know
Zach
Z's
um
Zappos his shoes oh big shoe guy
is this human what kind of like it's a
fancy shoe
the fanciest so he's a cobbler what is
happening I did you're plenty what do
you do
oh is this it it might be oh
[Music]
she can't take the army
that's nine points
she has to be able to do a city now
how many points do I have six
oh it shows nothing what happened you
had so many cars what is there I used to
build one settlement well
I did a I did a Dev card and I built a
settlement
well you're still last yeah I know
he's just because you said I might win I
don't know I got excited
what'd you get 12. it's like buying a
lottery ticket I might win
six
hell yeah it's about time it's uncovered
so on the road something crazy that
happened to me
what happened
um
I flew my drone
in the condo the comedy condo at Comedy
Works
and I was showing William Montgomery the
day and I moved to the left and it
crashed
you're on a brick Ridge wow
the crazy happens I I have wood
like both oh that's dangerous how many
points do you have if
I'll do it for one there's a sneaky dude
it's not a shown oh no this is
David
what do you need
I'll do it for uh I need a brick and
I'll give you either a weed or an orange
I only do it for so long
I can't do it
I am so tired guys
what yeah that's nothing to do with
anything I'm
fine
you've been up since Friday yeah
well what were you doing all day
long
interesting then I will only fire on
your boat like right there with you wow
no that's crazy
unleash fire on me yeah
do you have a goat no not that I can do
that
I don't like this how many do you have
seven oh I just made a deal with the
devil barely oh great that was eight oh
great no I don't what are you where are
you getting this aid from because I'd
like to know because you have five plus
two and now you're building a settlement
there's two in itself
hey
I shouldn't have done that oh wait but I
thought you had the night I wouldn't
have traded with your ass I thought you
were gonna me over damn it
and he's gonna get maybe along this road
too I don't know why you traded with him
he like threatens three God damn it I'm
just sitting duck
psychological and she made the right
choice
we in the rock
yes
wow
[Music]
okay
what am I doing
nothing we're moving on too many cards
for you
three
it's like who are you saying hi to
eight
oh
are we blocked
she's about to back into the board
it's about to back her ass into it
whoa
four five six seven eight
oh you need one more what do you need
more time
who's in the lead
what is this this is a great comeback
though I know at least I thought I
wasn't I thought you're dead in the
water yeah
we're all high and now Hans is
pretending he's not an egg
yeah
what what would you block of Hans is and
it's okay if it's blocking mine I'm
willing to sacrifice one of mine to walk
on uh what would I block mine I think I
think it makes sense that Hans is going
to try to build a house a settlement or
a city it's harder for but then again
this them up but what about that
week
so maybe we block
I think
it's nine six or I don't know if he's
gonna try to build a city or if he's
gonna try to build
settlement a settlement right
what city would get him more so it'd
have to be a right
I should block the same amount but he'll
have to spend five what should I do I'd
say you go to the
um the nine probably four the Niner and
four
a sheep
why the hell is sheep
if you hover the board you can look at
hans's face
luckily my face this is like uh people
play poker this is like our poker
anyways that was dumb
poker now how back in the day they used
to play poker oh
wait how many Death Cards does she have
she has nine points
[Music]
now I'm in last
the up well I am oh you're down
to six
nine
that's a good call
okay
I'm running out of roads I don't have
enough roads you have to use another
color
yeah they're supposed to be 15 I only
have not 15.
yeah I'm missing three yeah
[Music]
or you do something about it and build a
settlement here
oh you could cut it off okay okay and
she builds a settlement she wins yeah
and you win anyway okay
you wrote what that's actually what you
could get 12 points
world three no one it was an it was a
nine
all right
which is white yes I am white
and you're the devil
foreign
guys
oh
okay I don't have any cards
like this one you need it
so Ally's at nine Hans is there she's
not oh did you get wait take the longest
road so now you're at eight yeah and
she's it
or technically seven seven
or technically six
theoretically seven yeah
[Music]
whatever
three oh my gosh I can't get nothing
like wood
do you have a goat no
[Music]
on my back
I'm carrying this game
oh
I don't know
six
um
does anyone need a week
I can't fight with you at this stage
it's way too like six points no you have
nine points no I don't Hans took it back
for me I only have six what will you
trade for weight
um
I would trade either goat or wood
actually
I don't care about wood I need goat or
or I'll do it but you'll do or yeah
foreign
you're gonna give weight I'm giving
wheat will you throw in a wood
you have we had to turn this completely
on do you smoke Vape who's who's
a how many do you have nine
how many do you have
how many points do you have I got a set
seven how many points did you
I have seven out of eight
I could do
um wait you want Rock right no I need to
yeah but I would like I would with that
you don't have wood I don't have wood I
have zero wood I have a break I'll give
you a brick for two or
no I'll give you I can't wait what are
you at I'm at six
I have a second
what does I have
seven points okay
um I wanna roll out photo completely I
just let it go
Dylan
okay
yeah right you showed me off I thought
you were looking I thought you had a
door I have a wheat come on
I'm gonna help you more than trying to
help me do you have uh do you have uh I
only have this in breakfast how many
bricks I can't wait I don't want to do
it I don't I'm not going to trade
because if you I trade and you win
everyone gets mad at me
that's how you play the game yeah
well we'll get the least amount of
people to yell at him I feel like I've
been missing my knives
I feel like I just haven't been picking
up cards maybe they cover I'm humbling
sorry
with your ass
no you're gonna win
so you have one two three four five six
seven eight nine and I can't you're
gonna beat me no matter what because I
can't go in here not ten so you can only
tie me and never beat me exactly
it's good to be on top
no I'm at eight
seven and five really quick and I'm just
sort of petered out
what's that saying from Peter down
it's because of Peter the guy in the
Bible yeah it's like oh
what did Peter do you know before he was
his name was saw Saul before no Paul no
that's Saul Saul and Paul
Southall
nine wow oh
I need wood how do I on
you could you toss me someone yeah
oh you need to roll a seven
first off
oh right
okay
um
wait I'm I'm gonna do something
oh didn't pick up the night on the last
one
I picked it up I already picked it up
from the last one yeah you have to put
it down no I don't crazy no it's not I
didn't see the knife so the the we moved
on yeah that was in the past leaving in
the past you got to put it back move on
oh we rolled the five in the past let me
just pick up my let's bring it back
that's wild you guys see this awareness
you're being weird you're breaking the
rules I'm ready for you to roll no I'm
waiting for him so
all right I'm wrong about everything
Ally guys stop fighting stop fighting
I don't want to because I'm just trying
to encourage curds
cards honor roll whatever Hans doesn't
happen I have Ridge are you doing right
now yeah
oh does anyone want to make I don't want
to try it I traded with you manually
yeah what do you mean yeah I need I
guess I don't have much weight or wrong
I got super up I have a Wii but I
really need it do you want to to wood or
two sheep you can be a sheep and a wood
for you
for what for a week what let me see
the bird because after that I only have
I don't know this one all right a little
bit well big Treads happening big Treads
happening you're gone
did you just trade yourself into losing
no I don't I hope not no he didn't
it's about to have eight Corners two
four six eight
wow okay wait
on this next one I think
that's purely conjecture
um it definitely is
definitely hope we have seven
I know it'll hurt in a little short term
but in the long term wow look at her
stack of cards
eight
yeah
nice nice cover up
okay
let's see
this is such a clutch move really that
really Pro yeah
I'm glad I did that gave you that trade
such a loser mentality
homeless guy
so I want to help me cut off cons as a
long road what
oh no a settlement
whoa whoa
wait wait she's gonna win she's gonna
win the game yeah am I yeah
oh no oh
wait what
right you're done I'm not done
I'm just nervous
donut well I wouldn't if I put up yeah
yeah who do you want one more mirror I
could roll a seven I didn't want you to
win more but well do you wanna go if
Hans doesn't win on this next hand then
I'll trade with whatever you want
oh my gosh
wait what do you want in a week for an
hour
I guess I could I can't trade in for war
right now
what's this
oh my gosh I'm just putting cars
together
seven seven
Justice
two hours four how many Duos oh six nine
ten eleven I need to get rid of five
one two three four five
he could still put down a settlement
but he only has eight points
two four six eight yeah constantly has
eight points so if he breaks one more
yeah it's like it's under it's like when
it's on your YouTube channel
who's uh who's winning it's definitely
Dylan Dylan you're winning oh no no you
can steal from me but she's gonna win
this next hand I know I'm not how is she
gonna win I have nothing to win this
next challenge she could have two
pictures
no because I because I'm gonna do
something this way
so it doesn't really help
I don't really have anything
it's a joy to take from you okay
foreign
Trump
building
settlements
what was it what did you roll five yeah
okay uh
so how many part okay is that is that
score oh
um what do you need what do you need
I could probably use like a wood or like
a wheat yeah I got tons of tons of wood
tons of wood why do you want them to win
oh yeah true pull up that score Point
sheet again well I'm at eight but what
are you trying to do with this
Ally you're still at six
candles a little uh City over here
okay I'm trying to do a settlement on
the desert seven oh Ali you're so
confusing because I can't really build
it I don't have enough to be in that
City so I need a I don't like
what are you giving me
I'll give you a wood but what do I get I
can't do you want to give me nor
I haven't I have or I need I don't want
my arm can you give me a break wait I do
want my ore
o
wait what's this tray oh the train is
okay okay do you want a brick for your
wheat or
why do you need or if you're trying to
oh settlement I need a wheat I would
like an ore you need a wheat okay I
can't give you a week both
for a Wii and I'd give you a wood
so for three cards no
no
fine okay I think Ali she's sorry I'm
sorry she might have a night card
oh
oh that was good
thank you thank you
good game
wait wait wait wait how'd you win I
think you win Ally I got the big
whatever
such an unforced error there's you
didn't gain anything from that trade
yeah whatever it was fun yeah
yeah yeah yes I could maybe
that's seven saves you know
would you would you have one if it got
to you
yeah
okay four five six seven eight nine
forever well you could where would you
oh yeah I would have only had eight I
guess
you guys gassed me up you said you said
I was gonna win
I was wondering what was your scenario I
had two settlements I had like two years
and then if I rolled a seven you could
have been here yeah we're gonna build
one here at one here
that was Lucky Seven that saved you yeah
the seven
you were on the bus the entire time so
everyone was fighting you
it just looked impressive because you're
just all right no but I never but
longest road only gets you so so far you
know I have a theory that red pieces
game more yes yes
yeah that's why I like it because I'll
forget what color yeah
that's fun
ggs GG it's fun with four people yeah
really with four people you really get
like a lot of gameplay and we're we're
more trading and more scheming the
scheming
yeah I told you Dylan won last night I'm
like very autistic with the game where I
can't lie I'm just like yeah you showed
us your point I promise I'm good
well it works it works against me you
guys started to not trust me especially
the first game though I was like oh okay
I'll trade with her because she's being
like forthright about it yeah
yeah and I like how we can ask where are
you going with this yeah
too
how is this study
we all have five points for a while and
I have on this road for a while
longest road is so dangerous because it
takes up so many resources and it and
it's so obvious because it's on the
board
no
talking with each other and like trying
to get the weird you know like take a
card thing
yeah
thank you
in the yeah it's more emotional
it's way slower though I think
you should get
a sandwich
that would be good don't make the game
go a lot better yeah because we
sometimes just talk to each other but
that's also the fun part yeah
oh sorry
so you're staying one more day yeah and
you're gonna leave on Tuesday then
yeah
are you going straight to Michigan from
here I'm going home
Los Angeles Michigan yeah
all right
is everyone sad that you didn't win
hey oh bad friends
okay
uh you're not a bad friend to be honest
that's what I'm saying yeah
maybe this and chat the whole time
and pouring our hot turn inside that we
don't respect anymore
chat I hope they play spin the
bottlenecks
they look at Channel I don't know is
this what happens when a girl gets so
yeah
[Music]
that's what happens when the girls get
sober they start playing kitchen with
all the neurons
nerds win in the end
oh
okay
good playing with you